brielle nobody can see if i'm standing
up straight or not
do you look like a mummy dude relax
relax
that's what we want this is the dynamic
this is why you guys have a show we're
starting off the interview on this note
this is why you guys are on tv
let me tell you what she does to me all
the time ready i'll be doing an
interview or something and
she'll be in the room and she's like mom
i'm like what what and she's like your
neck and you gotta stretch it out so
nobody doesn't look old like
he's terrible she is terrible to me look
would you rather me not tell you and you
look 90
brielle i look amazing
younger this is true she's always like
mom your neck your neck come on like
your neck your hair your lips the face
everything we can always work on
let's get into don't be tardy we are
hitting the road this season
are we ready to go
[Applause]
five weeks all six kids why are we in a
bus why a
road trip whose idea was this oh
surprisingly
this was kim's idea to do the road trip
she's right i wanted to do this i
thought it would be a great idea
let's do like an rv trip for two weeks
well guess what bravo like ran
with it and it ended up being almost six
weeks um and that was a lot
it was a lot i wouldn't trade it for
anything but it was
a lot so safe to say you you probably
wouldn't do this journey again this was
a one-time experience
i think it was 118 degrees in arizona
the rv inside was 104 like an
ac can only do so much you know so
me being hot too it just doesn't it's
not good kim hot
it's really crazy to me that this is
like some people's dream like to take a
road trip across america and just see
what's going on in the world like
absolutely not
sounds like hell never doing it again
what was the better bus
experience this or the mini tour you and
candy took all those years ago on
housewives
this is not sweetie okay
this all day i'd rather do six weeks
with the fam than three days
on that bus i understand that in six
weeks tracked on a robust kim you have
made it no secret that you and kroy
10 years in you're still got an active
intimate life
yes so yeah
earmuffs maybe brielle um how how did
you handle that
on a bus with all your kids i mean our
room was in the very back of the rv
the very back so we were good you stole
time when you couldn't
yeah when we could yeah for sure what
did you learn about the family being in
such close quarters for such a long
amount of time what didn't we learn i
mean i learned everybody's schedules
for everything i think i i can tell you
everybody in this family's day
start to finish because it was all nice
we're pretty close
here i think we learned you know that
there's
when kim is hot don't even talk to me um
one comes out of wine don't talk to her
and if you don't find me pizza every day
don't [ __ ] her and i think it's kind of
like kim's world
in the rv like if kim's not happy
nobody's happy
is that different than just normal life
no
no believe it funny face one two three
the littles are not so little anymore
they are growing up
they are i mean some of them are almost
as tall as you guys
yes the littles have never known a life
without tv
so they ever like i don't want to be a
part of this please
these kids are like when are we filming
are we filming today like
well what should i wear like they love
it it's they do have days
where they'll be irritated about
something cash in particular will say
like i don't want to film today and it's
like okay don't film
whatever but our crew is our family are
like they've been a big part of our
family all these years they love the
cameras
you hear that that's god he's pissed
these kids are crazy
i want you guys on my tv forever but i
do want to know if you guys ever think
about
when would it be time to wrap things up
because your pals the kardashians
are shutting that chapter for them the
car the keeping up is ending so do you
ever think about
when will the right time be i do so they
have a lot more money
um they have a great legacy behind them
too i i've actually we had this
conversation the other day i said
if we did to season 10 like i think that
would be really cool to say that we've
done
10 but god forbid uh we just don't
continue on
after this season because this is really
such a great season if we ended it here
um i don't think any of us would be mad
we'd ended on a great note i mean we're
i would definitely be very sad we're
very
it's literally like family you know and
to say that you've had a tv show for as
long as we have is like
i feel like very unheard of um for just
one like it's still not good enough i'm
gonna keep going
it's the best job it's the best job in
the entire world i never want to give
that up i don't i can't see myself doing
anything else
but my passion my my life has been
television for 13 years
but i feel like we're so funny like why
would they want to get rid of that
god willing god willing i think this
season's
the best the best one yet honestly i
really do
i think it would be hard to top it but
i'm going to try to convince them
to let me maybe go to the mediterranean
and do like a yacht thing for six weeks
i think that would be really great a
whole below deck season with the
biermanns would be
yes probably break ratings records can
you imagine
i have made the very hard and difficult
decision to not
be a part of real housewives of atlanta
season 13. big news in the atlanta area
nene leakes is not returning to the real
housewives and i just wanted to get your
take on
that news she's an og that's sad yeah
you know i think
um it's i'm sure she's very sad it's
when i left when
i walked off um it was like traumatizing
to me i
was still like a death to me it was a
big part of my life you know
and i i think for her she probably feels
the same way but i also feel like
there's
time to move on you know so i do i wish
her well i think she'll be great
wherever she ends up
um but maybe it is time you know and
sometimes you have to be forced out
because you won't leave
so that you can move on and get
something better so i do wish you well
i'm still holding out hope for the road
trip show that was supposed to happen
that never happened
i know after this bus season you're
probably never going on the road again
but i'm still holding out hope for that
every single
day in my dm and on twitter i get about
the road
that's kind of funny who knows never say
[Music]
never